so now that you've got everything
installed it's ready to get going with
an app engine app we've created a very
simple hello world app engine
application that uses endpoints you can
find it in the lesson2 folder that you
downloaded from the Udacity github repo
for this course what we're going to do
now is import the project into eclipse
import the maven project into eclipse
you go up to the Eclipse menu you choose
file and then you choose import then you
open up the maven folder and choose
existing maven projects and then click
Next then you can browse to the folder
that has the project that you want to
import i unzip my folder in hello world
endpoints you have to select the folder
itself and then if you want in advanced
you can specify the name or you can use
the default name make sure that pom dot
XML selected click Next you may see you
get some errors particularly the end
points get discovery doc don't worry
about that just leave it as resolve
later and say finish it'll ask you if
you have the error you get a little
error message asking you if you really
want to continue and just say ok you do
and then the project comes in it's a
little hard to see here but my project
is hello world so this project that you
imported the hello world endpoints
project is a complete working app it's
very simple but it's complete it works
and you can run it out of the box so I'm
going to show you how to run it first
and then we're going to look into the
code that makes up the project so when
you're ready to run your project go over
here you choose it right click the
project choose run as and then go ahead
and choose run configurations you can
create a new launch configuration by
clicking this new launch configuration
button up here and enter the base
directory which is where your project is
but you can use this variable dollar
open brace project underscore lock that
points the directory where your project
is the goal you need to set it to App
Engine : dev server and down here in the
maven runtime you need to make sure that
the external maven runtime is selected
so it must say external
not internal if you need to configure it
and you click configure and make sure
that the global settings from
installation directory points to where
your maven is installed if you can't
remember where your mavens installed hop
over to a terminal console window and
hopefully during the maven installation
process you define the variable m to
underscore home so you can go ahead and
just echo that so I'll say ok and say
apply and then right here I could go
ahead and run it or I could close it but
I'll run it now and you see it starts
compiling and you see here it's
retrieving the Google App Engine Java
SDK from maven and that's because in the
pom dot XML we've specified the Google
App Engine SDK as one of the
dependencies first time you run it it
does take a while because maven has to
go off and get all the libraries and
everything that make up the dependencies
in your project and when it's finished
you'll see build success so the build
success means it's finished building and
now it's going to actually start running
it and when it when the project is
running on the dev server on localhost
you see this message in faux dev
appserver is now running so let's make
sure it really is so I open the browser
and go to a new tab and go to localhost
colon 8080 and if for any reason your
app is running on different port then
just use a different port but I expect
it'll be localhost 8080 and look the app
is running we're not actually going to
run the app I mean you're welcome to run
it if you want to but that's not what
we're going to look at next so now I
just want to show you how to deploy to
App spot so back here in the in Eclipse
go ahead and select your project right
click it again choose run as and run
configurations click new to add a new
configuration gain add the base
directory and I can just copied out
variable into my new configuration now
this time we want to deploy it to App
spot so for that you have to add the
goal app engine colon update so here's a
goal App Engine colon update again make
sure that the maven runtime is says
external now you can run it now the
first time you run it though you're
going to need to give me
to the App Engine CFG application which
is an app engine application that will
upload your app engine application and
you'll see that it's asking permission
to view and manage your applications
deployed on Google App Engine you are
going to need to accept this and after
accept it you'll see that it shows you a
code says please copy this code and
paste it so go ahead and copy the entire
code and then go back to eclipse and
enter the code hit return and it will
keep going oh no goodness I've got
another error 403 forbidden you do not
have permission to modify this app app
ID equals your app ID oh no wait wait
that's not my app ID I forgot to
configure the App Engine web XML and
you're going to need to do this too so
you go into the source directory SRC
source and then into the main not
looking at Java just now you need to go
into the web app der then you need to go
and go into web intents and you see App
Engine web dot XML and this file is
where you configure the properties are
very specific to App Engine and the most
important one for deploying to App
Engine is you have to enter the app ID
of your project and this is the ID that
you set in the developer console over on
console developers comm so go ahead and
enter your app ID here save the file and
try running again
now this time just go to run as maven
build and pick the run configuration for
App Engine update I forgot to name mine
but here I see it's App Engine update ok
good it's beginning the interaction see
it's initiating its cloning it's
uploading then it reaches a point where
it's pretty much uploaded stuff but it
needs to ping the app to verify you'll
see these messages we'll check again in
1 2 seconds and so on and at this point
all it's really doing is just trying to
ping the app can sometimes get hung here
but usually it doesn't take very long
ok good so now then again you see build
success now this means that my
apps now been deployed to appspot let's
go check
so to visit your app running on appspot
you go to your app ID whatever that is
and then after your app ID you do
appspot.com
and it should take you to your app and
this looks exactly the same as it did on
localhost but actually we're now running
it on appspot so one more thing I wanted
to mention in your project is that after
you deploy it whether you deploy it to
localhost or you deploy it to app spot
the target directory gets populated with
all the compiled code so you could
actually delete the target directory and
then rerun your project and it would get
recreated